The Joe Rogan experience,
do you,
you'll never allow yourself to get back to 300 pounds?
Can Oh,
never.
No,
no,
no.
I can't go down that road yet.
Crazy transition though to go at a 10 year span from being a guy who's like
really overweight and worried you're going to die to being an elite UFC fighter.
Yeah.
Like life life for me is as is happening now.
Like this is kind of the beginning of everything for me.
You know,
it's,
it's really cool.
That's really cool and I'm glad that I found mixed martial arts just because it
just,
it gives me,
it's a journey man.
It's not just UFC,
just like finding MMA and diving into different cultures and lifestyles and
understandings and sometimes philosophies,
all this stuff.
Just to understand,
just to put it all together,
just to have it all make sense at the end of the day.
Like it's,
it's been a beautiful thing.
Been able to meet a lot of people,
go a lot of places like I'm very thankful and very just like,
like I'm okay with life.
You know?
It's very good to hear,
man.
That's a cool thing to hear.
I love hearing that you're cool cooled life and yeah,
you're um,
you're on a great path,
man.
It's a,
it's also what's inspiring about it for other people is your story of being at a
place where you weren't like that before and your story of being overweight and
smoking cigarettes and feeling depressed and then now you're like for so many
people out there that gives people hope,
it gives them a thought.
Like maybe if I just figured this out,
I actually can't,
maybe life doesn't suck.
Maybe just sucks the way on living.
Maybe if I could just figure out this path in a positive direction,
I can change everything I can.
I could be a happy,
I could be like you right now.
What was the exact quote?
I'm happy with that.
Happy with life.
Yeah.
You're cool with life.
I'm happy with life.
That is a great quote.
Most people don't get to that spot and the crazy thing is too,
I didn't have this dream to be in the UFC.
I made a choice to just go get healthy.
You gave me,
it was like doing a short,
just a short step in the right direction and I just,
what propelled you to take the first fight if you were just trying to get
healthy?
Uh,
a lot of encouragement and the first time really hearing people like being good
at something that like
I was like surrounded by fighters and guys who believed in me and like who cared
and like wanting to see me get better and tougher and I was getting my ass
kicked every day and that was something that wasn't used to just being in that
environment I had at the time learning,
I had a very strong team.
Like I started at Vandelay school when he was still fighting.
So a lot of the guys,
I was like shoot the box style.
It's like everyone's getting knocked out.
Every training somebody gets knocked out really very hard.
And that was,
that was new for me to get and like that and how to varying that in Vegas.
Oh yeah man.
I remember helping him get ready for the either it was like Brian Sander Krystle
Ebid and throwing full on the elbows in the cage.
No Pad.
Like we're going at it.
I'm like,
my jaw was dislocated everything,
but it was just like what we learned was just always fight in Brazilian.
They pull Hada every day.
Wow.
Everyday People Hada
blow hod the,
yeah.
Think about that.
Um,
it definitely made me tough in the beginning.
Now I,
I realize that like I've only been doing this a short time and I already feel
like aches and pains and stuff and I don't want it to be like that when I'm
older.
So I'm a lot more smart about my training.
And uh,
do you think it was a critical aspect of your success though?
I needed gone through the fire like that.
I needed that because you were saying different guys,
you know what I was made of,
right.
Being,
being a guy who's overweight and secure,
all these things,
never going on hikes or my dad passed away when I was younger,
like very young.
And so I never had my dad to encourage me to go throw a ball or anything,
play sports or be a man,
be a boy,
be at,
you know,
just be,
I was always like kind of sheltered by my mom and she was more like protective,
like,
ah,
I don't wanna go do that.
And then she finally learned to just like set me free.
But I needed to know what I was made of,
man.
I needed to know what I was made of in,
yeah,
in the realm of,
of med fighting,
whatever,
it took blood tears,
sweat had the same thing that I say.
Like I didn't know what that was like.
I never got a taste of it.
And so going through it in a real way of like actually getting my ass beat and
having to find my way out of it and can't run from it and still like it's people
that cared about me too.
It was like,
it was just a great thing to have.
And now I enjoy it.
I enjoy really good,
hard fight.
You know what I mean?
Something about it.
That's,
well you're,
you,
you're enjoying your progress to your change of who you are as a person.
You're strengthening.
How far into your training was where you like 100% all in committed like that?
Uh,
I think it was after my loss to Tyson Pedro,
which was my second fight in the UFC,
um,
before everything was still kind of very fun and games and I was like,
oh,
I get to travel,
go to Australia to fight in Australia.
So it was a big shock to be in the UFC,
especially not even expecting to be there.
And within just a few years.
So,
uh,
after losing that fight is when I met my friend and at the time my strength and
conditioning coach Lorenzo and he had been through,
um,
like para rescue school and things like that.
So he helped me to just develop this mentality of like,
how far will your mind take you,
how big is your will?
And when training with him and doing kind of like pararescue survival training
for conditioning,
that,
that was a,
that was a point where I started to like say like,
okay,
I'm going to take this full on.
I know I can fight hard,
but now I know how far am I will can go in the face of the elements and
everything.
So like putting those two together,
going after it.
And then the,
the fight I took after that was Daniel Jolly and then I ended that in the first
round with the knee.
And then I thought Paul Craig in Scotland and I had the same mentality.
Like,
I'm going forward,
I'm getting better,
I'm going to grow stronger,
better,
harder,
like everything.
And uh,
then the,
the fight to the Polish guy,
uh,
Michael Alexei joke.
Have you seen him lately?
He's been,
he's been a,
he just beat like John Volante and I forgot.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
that was the body shop.
I lost it.
All right.
I lost to him,
but then it got turned to a no contest.
So,
um,
after that was a go Saki fight.
So it's been three years and no contest.
Did he test positive?
Yeah.
Tested positive,
but he was also,
um,
uh,
a last minute,
last minute fight.
I always fuck his name up.
Michael l Alexi joke.
Oh,
Alexi.
Check.
Yeah.
It's a rough one.
At the weigh ins.
I was butchering
terrible.
But some of those fucking names.
Ah,
sage.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So when like three or four years,
man,
and how many fights you have professionally?
Uh,
Dang.
What's my work?
83 83 and one that's funny that you know,
you don't really know your record.
I,
hmm.
I don't remember.
Eight three in one.
I think it's 83 and one.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's amazing that you've been fighting for a relatively short period of time
and have a,
achieved some pretty fucking spectacular results,
man.
[inaudible].